listen with Borderlands the pre-sequel
about a week away it's time to start
preparing yourself no I'm not talking
about starting a new Borderlands 2
character or downloading all that
headhunter DLC honestly that wouldn't be
a bad start I'm talking about your
mental game you don't just want to be
good at the game when it comes out you
don't want to be merely great at
shooting things on a weird-ass mood you
want to be legendary and since the only
way to accomplish anything in life
anymore is to follow a list on the
Internet we've assembled this quick and
easy guide to becoming legend in
Borderlands the pre-sequel for you and
your fellow vault hunter friends to
enjoy and cherish step 1 get boozed up
look I'm not saying you need to drink to
be cool just that you'd be a lot cooler
if you drank but you don't have to take
my peer pressure for it head on over to
Moxie's up over bar and peruse the
merchandise yourself if Elvis had a
health code and probably be a serious
violation for moxie to just leave the
drinks out on the bar for you to
purchase but just look at the stat boost
these suckers will give you plus 30%
melee damage for downing bricks fist
that'll make even claptraps pathetic
poke attack pack a punch slurp down a
finale and Toddie and get a 20% increase
to damage resistance let's see those
dragons barf lava on you now haha space
gags I find it refreshing and not at all
uncomfortable there are eight of these
mocks tails on display and no bouncer in
sight so throw down some moonstone throw
back a drink and enjoy thirty minutes of
a temporarily juiced up you only one can
be active at a time so choose wisely and
yes I said moonstone so spend wisely on
with the list step two in Borderlands
the pre-sequel equip legendary weapons I
mean yeah it's a bit of a no-brainer but
what you expect so check out these two
legendary beauties we got to test drive
the cutting-edge fate I'll name seems a
tad redundant but when you consider that
this SMG is basically built to quickly
freeze and
so you can dice them up with those two
pokey bits it certainly seems to fit
smashing frozen enemies is one of the
great new pleasures in the pre-sequel
and doing so with a gun named after the
1992 drama romance sport classic the
cutting edge much the zx1 is the other
weapon we got to fool around with and
let me tell ya this is one hot little
number yes that's an elemental damage
pawn hit no I feel no shame a 100%
accurate fiery laser beam that
penetrates enemies and becomes burst
fire when zoom I mean I'm not totally
sold on that last step but what the hell
sign me up just gotta make sure you find
yourself some atmosphere with this one
because you know what they say in
atmosphere fire burns deer in void of
space you can't melt face atrocious our
last tip for becoming legendary is step
3 but stop everything everywhere all the
time forever okay look I know what
you're thinking what if I'm BOTS dumping
all the time how will I use my legendary
weapon well for one you probably won't
pick up a weapon right off the bat so
you need something to kill the time and
for to shut up and start but stomping
but stomp people but stop Cragen's but
stop giant floating you tainted squid
horror okay no that's gross just stay in
your moon book but stop dudes outside
but stomp dudes inside but stop even if
you're a TWiki little robot with no
actual button but stop near but stomp
far but stop in your hover car but stop
here but stop there but stop freaking
everywhere
there you have it the top three ways to
become a legendary moon badass in
Borderlands the pre-sequel courtesy of
gamespot.com for you our beloved viewer
study this video extensively and you too
will be ready to live the legendary life
when your bizarro moon adventures begin
yeah I know I didn't use the place no I
was tired of it I can't say legendary
that way one more time no I won't do it
legendary